boy when I miss a day or a few you
people really want your avatar view long
so uh yeah
here is a peso sixteen the deserter um
and this is one I would almost put in
the filler category but I think there's
enough that I saw I said okay this is
this is good to know like this was good
information to know um in this one they
go to they start going to this carnival
run by the Fire Nation which come on
guys does that sound remotely like a
good idea but okay so they they go this
place they accidentally out themselves
and get chased out honestly you probably
could cut that whole bit um and they
come across this guy who says that he
knows a firebender who's not part of the
Fire Nation eight he reminds me a lot
sort of desk hopper from Apocalypse Now
like if he's a cheese man he's no genius
so they go to visit this guy and Aang
thinks well this is great he can master
firebending and they come across this
person and he does not want to teach and
he doesn't want to teach him not just
because he's a kid but because he
doesn't want to teach anyone this
firebending uh at least not anyone who
doesn't have this incredible restraint
and control over them and even though
Aang is a very likable kid has these
wonderful attributes he's still a kid he
supposed to be taught a lot of this
stuff and he sees as a big mistake
the reason being and this is why I think
this episode does is a little better
than just a filler episode it's because
he was saying unlike the other elements
this is an element that is actually
designed to destroy in a sense you know
a water really is an earth really isn't
air really isn't I mean they can but
that's not sort of their only function
fire is pretty much made to destroy
something and you can get stuff out of
it but it's made to destroy and what's
interesting about that is that suddenly
it makes sense how the Fire Nation came
to take over everything and why they
feel they want to take over
everything if you have this power that
naturally wants to destroy and consume
it makes sense so I found that very
fascinating that this guy did not want
to teach and you know even though hang
is a nice kid uh and eventually he gives
in because the inner avatar in Aang
comes out and I like that scene again
you don't know exactly what he can do
and I love I love the way they do it
it's not like a big explosion or big
boom of light just the lights go out
comes back on and there he is there's
the the older avatar I thought that was
a very nice way of doing it it sort of
gives you a double take to so it's that
was very nicely handled uh some of this
stuff again and I know Aang's a kid and
we don't know where he was in his
training some of it I do sort of well
that again I my original mindset was
that he should know some of the stuff
that this does take time that this does
take patience and he's willing to do it
I will say that what is interesting is
that he keeps the teacher keeps saying
on this mountain doing these exercises
for like hours if it was an hour or ten
minutes or something like that and Hank
came back at me like am i kid you have
to know better than this but granted
hours plural is a while so I think
that's a little bit more identifiable
the more I think about it what bothered
me a little bit is that I don't like how
Aang was kind of showing off with the
fire after you know he's finally
starting to get it down after he was
taught so much just driven into him
don't show off use it responsibly
restrained and stuff like that you know
just immediately he shows off and that I
don't know that got to me a Singh
smarter than that and I know he's a
little kid and but the way they're
building this kid up he seemed wiser
than that and again he merely knows his
mistake and he apologizes and
understands if he should not be shown
how to do this or if he should keep away
from the fire because he knows I get
burned or his you know possible most
likely future girlfriend will get burned
and then that's another element is that
she gets her hands burned goes puts her
hands in the water heals herself and the
teachers like you're a healer she's like
yeah but what did she always know this
was this a new development is she find
that out at the time it's done very
vaguely and very quickly and I'm still
not sure like was at that sort scene I
have a blue I didn't even know water was
part of like you know was a healing art
or whatever so so that was a little
weird that could have been explained
better but I like also what came in uh
pretty smart was that I'm just gonna
call in the Malfoy general because I
know the guy who was one of the Malfoy's
plays this voice I'm just always gonna
call on that or maybe I'll get his name
I mean I'll give their the other names
but for now he's Malfoy in general uh he
comes in the teacher has explained that
this guy does not have self-control
that's one of the reasons he became this
general for this evil army and and comes
across him they have this duel and
clearly cannot outdo this guy I mean he
has fire coming at him and Aang it's not
powerful enough so he has to use his wit
and he remembers what he said that he
was a student and he did not have
self-control so I like that he used his
knowledge of his own self-control and
his own anger in his own frustration to
use against him and ran around the ships
and kept me get angry and angry or
taunting him saying how bad his powers
are and so forth and what insult he is
he's not even feeling it and make him
matter matter because we get more and
more angry get more and more stupid and
he burns the ships and they have no way
to get back so that that was nicely good
I like how that all tied together
I wish there could have been a little
bit more time if they if they took out
the carnival they probably could had a
little bit more time to dedicate to that
and some of these things would have
connected a little better but they
connected okay um so it is a good
episode and it goes a little bit
the filler because I think it gives a
little background just into the nature
of the fire nation without necessarily
having to spell it out for you I think
this episode even if you don't explain
too much else I'm sure they will go into
more detail but even if you don't
explain too much else you understand how
the Fire Nation took over just by the
nature of fire and what they are I don't
know if it's born with or whatever but
what they're growing up with so that's I
found that very fascinating if they do
give more detail great but they have it
set and I thought just by these little
hints and not even saying this is why
the Fire Nation is like this just saying
this is what fire is like I thought that
was a very clever way of actually
showing a lot of human nature in a sense
if you were growing up with this power
you probably be a little bit of a bully
too because that is a lot of power to be
growing up with so yeah it was a good
episode I did enjoy it I do wish other
parts got more focus and and like I say
always the opening could probably just
been cut out uh but I did enjoy it so
good episode see you number 17